pressure get packed up for 24 hours yeah
yeah
hi I'm Merle hi there I'm aria it's
great we're gonna talk together for 24
hours it's horrible that's a real treat
for you huh getting Hank up to me for 24
hours I know you've been really
anticipating this day a fair bit know
each other for like what five months so
we're coworkers we working the same team
together everybody in the office thinks
that we have like crushes on each other
everyone the comments in the video Steve
we have been in several videos together
a barrage of comments seem to always
flood these videos shipping the two of
us together they seem to send some sort
of chemistry I don't think Maya they're
not dating
we're coworkers we're also very good
friends we know each other very well we
do have a really great chemistry you
know it's never boring but we're not
dating
we're not dating dating in the workplace
is your on and on and on I'll tell you
why we're not dating
we're not dating because I've wanted to
be single are you gonna make it look
like I'm the crazy one here no yes she's
needed to be single for a while and I
just don't think dating in the workplace
is a good idea it's unprofessional yeah
we're gonna go plant shopping cuz Aria
need some plants for his apartment then
we're gonna cook a nice vegan meal maybe
watch a movie tonight we both like
horror movies I actually have to pick up
some stuff from a fight shop maybe get
you some some hand wrap some good
punching gloves
yeah I'm looking forward to kind of
seeing Aria in his day to day life I'm
not looking forward to getting in his
car with him because he's a terrible
driver and also I don't know about the
sleeping situation we've never slept
together that's intense I'm excited for
the cooking but I'm also dreading it
because the fact that we're hanging up
together cooking multiple dishes that's
gonna be quite a stressful situation the
only rule is that we're allowed to
uncuffed three times I don't want to see
what goes on the bathroom with you I'll
just leave me to that that might have
been a step too far that would have
really destroyed anything from but
they're so happening at any time have we
ever kissed we have not kissed I guess
let's get a magical moment
we broke the other pair because they're
both so strong these are even more
heavy-duty have we got a disclaimer
there's only one key there's only one
key and if we lose this key and we call
a locksmith to let us out they are
legally obligated to inform the police
and the police officer has to be present
for that moment and so I'd really like
to not have a police officer come to out
of our places to observe us getting
uncuffed mistakes just went out well you
know holding out of the key yes you
certainly will be let's try this again
Jesus this feels so much more grave
these aren't breaking no these are not
[Laughter]
after we got handcuffed we went out onto
the BuzzFeed campus got a lot of remarks
to a lot of eyes is it fine are you
having so much fun unless you're insane
oh that's been challenging 20 minutes
precious it has up to 24 enjoying oil
too much around the office yeah I think
they got a kick out of it I think
somebody is planning ahead
now we're getting going to the car we're
gonna have to try and find a way to get
inside the car you begin to the
passenger side I've been the passenger
oh nice job he's so nimble you did great
shopping all right now we're going into
the pet shop the plant shop that I go to
often he got three plans for his
apartment some really easy to take care
of low maintenance plan oh sorry yes
neon pathos though I know he likes me
spent $40 on playing oh hi I'm already
from BuzzFeed I'm stuck to him and stuck
to him right now but I should also say
yes he's out bursaries screams that this
is his world this is my world
and orange screams at the top is live
and normally I can like politely step
aside I actually do enjoy it I find it
very entertaining and funny what you
come to him that it looks like I'm also
crazy their thing is that you mask your
crazy but now I have three real plants
will they survive a week we'll see okay
then next we want to visit my fight shop
that's where I punched him in the head
yeah but yeah we're looking through some
hand wraps I like red
oh but yellow is my whole life Sorry
Sorry Sorry do the red do the red also
we just want to try some head your honor
that's all right maybe he's a masochist
I don't know but he was like I'm gonna
put on the peg gear Europe on this glove
now me as hard as you can this is the
most excited I've been all day I just
wanted to show a how wonderfully strong
I am be Arya's doing a nice thing now
and he's helping me make a copy of my
house key okay so now we're on the way
to get this woman her keys are his
dreams just came through we walked into
the store and he went up this Yelp this
must feel very romantic I was supportive
more love for the holidays look at those
trees well apparently Merle has I lost
the key to call the police we kept any
speed you were as soon as possible up
until I know what on the ground we were
looking at the Christmas trees remember
good you know what this video needs some
drama I don't want to be dealing with
the police today art is actually
thrilled with the idea that wouldn't be
able to
I don't want to see the cops know that
I'm not made it out we don't need to
call the police that was almost really
bad yeah well back - yeah all right we
are back at my place now it's nowhere we
have put these plants there aren't very
many plants in the privacy this is a
nice room it's very and it seems very
empty got any greenery ranked viewed in
the or okay I don't like this the same
plant the same books I hate snakes
yeah that being said we're gonna put
that in this room this is little speech
Ivy to replace that fake plant over
there where does it go you put in the
bathroom there's no windows in there
great puzzle in place we got one here on
my desk that one's at least here they're
a fake plant used to be and then the
other one is in the bedroom great job
yes did a great job feels like home here
now yes this is a head wrap so that way
your knuckles he's just trying to hold
anything we got to give our nice nice
point because I have a very old cat who
isn't doing well and so I don't want to
leave her alone tonight
so we're gonna go stay at my place so
she's not long
yeah so on the way there also the
groceries for Derek oh yeah so we
haven't figured it we just got out of a
very healthy different supermarket then
roll in there
that let's do this together
all right so we have a lick of alcohol
we're supposed to make dinner hey I'm
responsible for dessert I'm going to
make these beautiful Vita cinnamon rolls
supposed to do stuff with my hands your
hands are still available yeah same time
well last night I really made some
terrible cinnamon rolls I butchered
these beacon cinnamon rolls okay
yes we're back it is about an hour into
process it was time to check on his
dough I think I killed my daughter so I
thought it's not doing too hot
unfortunately but you know I've made
dumpling soup which looks delicious
smells good doesn't it so he's gonna
roll this out and then he's gonna put it
in here
and then we're gonna layer it with rums
sugar and cinnamon right yeah all right
dumpling soup yeah it's it's very good
it's very tasty honestly the cinnamon
rolls are currently in the oven I love
horror movies guys do i paterns out he
also does and it's Halloween season
so wherever watch the orphanage but my
tells me he's like a jumpy person okay
wow you got the icing so changes on this
on top I can create good top out great
if you go for the uncooked parts let's
go
[Laughter]
we actually left twice at the end of the
night
well we a couple months had to use the
restroom each and then we then uncuffed
later in the night to shower and change
Shh
after the movie ended well we stopped
the movie actually because she fell
asleep and so we decided to just get
ready for bed
yeah so I'm taking this opportunity
because Aria doesn't flops yes I don't
like the blood I don't know if you know
this the flossing is more important than
brushing yes that's true you're not
doing hang tough in bed Stan you're so
bed yep very good yeah I'm tired I just
know it could be bad we started like
separated from each other no cuddles no
cuddly it's a small bed it's a small
these are clothes and her bedsheets
they're not very odd it's cold morning
through the night it's nothing happened
happened now we're gonna go to work and
things off I mean honestly this was a
very nice 24 hours before we started
this I was worried about this possibly
you know just making us hate each other
but if anything I think I brought us
close together we had a lot of lot of
good times I will say that I enjoy Merl
because she is very easy to be around
we always have a good time Aria makes me
laugh more than I maybe anybody she's
never boring it's very easy it's very
natural with Merle I feel like I can be
myself like truly we know that we can
spend her long periods of time with each
other outside of the office would you
call that dating no two buddies hanging
out for camera of course not
very small crush miniscule so miniscule
that HR can't them yeah you can't get
them yeah honestly I had a great time
and there's truly no one else I would
rather be handcuffed to the room
ah great get back to my life now this is
my world this is my world
[Music]